i think it's important not to celebrate
prematurely
the student loan debt forgiveness that
has been announced by joe biden and the
reason i say that is that it is looking
slightly more plausible
that that student loan debt forgiveness
could end up blocked now earlier in the
week we discussed this on the bonus show
and when we talked about it on the bonus
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
fund themselves is bad among other
things one of the things that came up is
that
disgusting republican senator ted cruz
is working on blocking it and one of the
things that came up in our discussion
about ted cruz is that even ted cruz was
admitting
he isn't totally clear on who could
bring a lawsuit could it be a taxpayer
who says hey
twenty one hundred dollars supposedly of
my tax money is being used to pay off
someone's student loans or to forgive
someone student loans
and that hurts me so i'm filing a
lawsuit would a random taxpayer have
standing what about someone who just is
outside of the income range for
forgiveness like if you make 126 000
instead of 125 000 it's not clear
but increasingly
it seems as though it is at least
plausible that the plan could be blocked
arizona's republican attorney general
said he and others are looking at
bringing a legal challenge
to joe biden's plan for the cancellation
of student debt
if we can bring a challenge we will
bring a challenge
he said to cnbc in an interview on
tuesday
the state's republican attorney general
said he and others are looking to bring
a challenge
and uh gop attorneys attorneys general
from missouri and texas as well as ted
cruz who i already mentioned
all are figuring out how might we be
able to block joe biden's plan
and this is causing understandable
anxiety for the tens of millions that
stand to benefit from this plan
now as cnbc writes a drawn-out legal
challenge would threaten to throw the
fate of an estimated 43 million people's
debts into limbo for the foreseeable
future and the issue could
make its way to the supreme court
lawrence tribe harvard law professor
wrote the uncertainty for borrowers in
the meantime is considerable
no lawsuits have yet been filed
but it looks like they want to do it
sooner than later
so there's a couple of different things
here that i think are important
one is yes
it is completely plausible at this point
based on all of the legal uh opinions
i've read it is plausible
that
this could be tied up for years
now whether ultimately it will be found
to be within joe biden's
purview and something he can do and
something that's legal and something
that can be done i don't know but if it
gets tied up for years before any
forgiveness is done that's still going
to be very bad for 43 million borrowers
that's number one number two
this also could backfire on republicans
we have seen for months now
the chances for democrats in the house
and senate tick up and up and up slowly
yes but they have ticked up and up and
up
and part of that is on the backs of the
overturning of roe v wade much too much
celebrated by many republican officials
not popular with the american public
part of it has been republican in action
on gun safety
and we know from polling
that this level this degree of student
loan debt forgiveness that has been
offered
is quite popular with the american
people so while indeed it is something
republicans might be able to hold up
it also appears to be something that
republicans should be cautious about
holding up because it does not seem as
though the the american people actually
want it stopped but at this point it is
getting enough momentum behind it the
block the forgiveness movement that it
would be weird not to mention the fact
that it is not a complete and total
foregone conclusion
one of our sponsors is little spoon your
one stop shop for healthy easy meals and
snacks for your baby toddler or big kid
delivered right to your door with fresh
organic baby food for every stage
toddler and kids meals that even the
picky eaters will love
and the new line of healthy smoothies
little spoon has you covered little
spoon makes everything fresh it's just
like homemade it's ready in mere moments
all of the recipes are delicious they're
nutritionally balanced and free of junk
little spoons baby food is 100 organic
and cold pressed for every eating stage
for toddlers and kids little spoon has
the classics mac and cheese but they'll
sneak things in like butternut squash
and carrots they have more adventurous
meals cheesy pupusas or chicken pot
stickers they're all kid approved packed
with nutrients and little spoons organic
smoothies are perfect when you need
something quick and easy and the best
part is kids meals under six dollars and
baby food and smoothies under three
dollars each plus you'll get fifty
percent off your first order when you go
to littlespoon.com and use the coupon
code pacman50 the link is down below